uh there is such thing as toxic
positivity but toxic positivity is
different than being an eternal optimist
toxic positivity is blindly believing
everything good when it's not like
everything's fine everything's good here
and telling your team hey look hey look
everything's fine everything's good look
at look look at the bright side look at
the bright side when you're going
through stress and horrible things
um if you're truly an optimist it means
you believe the future is bright but you
can absolutely be realistic about
darkness that we're in currently
um you know I'm an optimist I'm also a
realist I can also say hey this is a
really tough time I'm struggling we're
struggling the team is struggling this
is this is gonna suck for about eight
weeks but I know if we work together and
take care of each other we will get
through this in better shape than than
we went into it
um so that's that's optimism but it's
also it's also realism toxic positivity
is ignoring and denying reality where
struggle may be may be part of it